the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay we have our class we've done pretty
much everything up until here and we're
going to add this special function here
so we're implementing this underscore
underscore EQ underscore underscore and
implementing this is going to is going
to allow us to compare two types of cars
so the way I've decided to compare two
types of cars is I'm saying the two cars
are going to be equal if they have the
same number of wheels they have the same
color and if they have the same number
of doors okay so if all of these are
equal then return true and else return
false inside the actual program here I'm
creating one car four wheels two doors
I'm changing its color to red I'm
creating another car four wheels two
doors by default this new car or your
car is going to have the color empty
string because that's how a new car gets
initialized right so between my car in
your car the difference is going to be
the color okay so the color is not going
to be the same they have the same number
of wheels in the same number of doors so
when so because I implemented the equal
method in my code this does not throw an
error this lets me proceed it compares
four with four which is good two with
two which is good and then the colors
don't match so it's going to say false
which most of you guys are getting it
right